you know because you want to say
something George you look like you're
pondering yeah what are you asking me a
thing maybe I'm wrong try to convince me
get on a mic here
are you sick is he gonna get sick from
your mic don't get too close to it what
do you consider a radical idea firstly I
think a radical idea saying is like
saying something like black people are
less than other whites is a radical idea
another radical idea would be that gays
are abominations and they don't deserve
to go to heaven or they are not allowed
to get married or they don't have
certain rights than other people right
you know or you know me and things of
that nature yeah and I think that an
idea of I don't think that Muslims know
Muslims are allowed in this country is a
radical idea it is a radical idea and if
somebody believes that in my head it
says Oh number one you don't have any
Muslim friends because if you had Muslim
friends which I do you wouldn't think
that way because my friends aren't
violent they don't have crazy they just
they're I think that anyone involved in
any kind of religion is weird you know I
believe that if you're fanatical about
some sort of prehistoric book that was
written thousands of years ago and you
literally believe you know what the book
this piece of literature says then it's
a little weird blind faith and anything
whether it's veganism whether it's
animals whether it's you know religion
any type of fanatical behavior is very
creepy to me like Alcoholics Anonymous
has a book and they say the big book is
the end-all you know it's like I read it
and I take things out of it that I can
use in my life but I don't believe that
it's you know everything that 12-step
groups stand for I believe that it is
our Bible per se but even in the book
you know it says these are just
suggestions riot which makes me go oh
can take certain things and leave it you
know a lot of people that dive into a a
and they do everything the book says
usually they stay sober longer but still
they don't cram it down your throat or
they don't make it a universal law you
know so that's what I believe now what
are you gonna say okay I think I agree
with you
my main two points I like I have a lot
of very religious family like my
extended family is all very religious
okay that's right that's why I wanted to
ask you George so you grew up with what
religion seventh-day Adventist we're
very obscure we're just like Mormons
only we're right mm-hmm
now we're getting into some stuff here
yeah go ahead but then I actually then I
also grew up right next to a Muhammad
Ali
Ono in a Michigan yeah so let me ask you
something are you active in your
religion a funny story I actually lost
my religion because of Muhammad Ali did
you yeah it was like a big factor he he
would always try like my parents land is
right like borders his land so we share
a fence like we grow plants on his land
yes Wow he was the nicest guy ever so he
was a very radical in his Islam like it
yeah he was a very development so a
counterpoint just to like being radical
in a sense
is that he was the nicest most generous
person ever but I'm not sure he's
radical in the sense that you're against
because people from every religion spoke
at his funeral right right but back to
yeah he so he would always give me Bible
studies and because seventh-day
Adventism takes such a literal view of
the Bible like this is exactly what
happened we believe in exactly exactly
you know five thousand-year-old earth
all that stuff mm-hmm
so Muhammad would do Bible studies and
find like all the errors in the Bible
like this part of Kings disagrees with
this part of Corinthians you know were
there 7,000 over there 5,000 he would
have kids come to his house and you do
Bible studies no it's just me it would
like if I visited wow you used to go to
his house and you weren't kidding you
were legit neighbors yeah no my parents
went to the funeral
I regret what I said about Kimbo versus
Muhammad Ali now because now that I
think you know I but if the bigness and
the history and everything that that man
paved Muhammad Ali is probably one of
the most prolific figures in sports
history ever yeah I still get goosebumps
anytime I hear him speak yeah yeah
George I never I never knew this to this
extent I knew that you lived near him at
some point in the same town but I never
knew you
your parents grew plants in his yard
yeah cuz he had like a big field and my
parents like we're looking for more
farmland and they my dad was like hey
you just got weeds in this land let's
make it pretty ok so tell us how the
transition happened so you were seven
day Adventists and how did he bring you
out of that how did he bring you out he
was trying to convert me to Islam by
telling showing me that the Quran is
like doesn't contradict itself right so
but he had this big old book of every
contradiction in the Bible and I was
thinking like that does not quite work
with a literal interpretation of the
Bible mm-hmm and I was like no I I want
to drink coffee I want to drink beer I
want to have sex
what are your restrictions of seven day
Adventists that's what it's saying it's
very close to Mormonism that came out of
like the late 1800s all that religious
fervor in the u.s. okay so it's going
back to the basics of Christianity where
like Jesus's religion is a people
worshiped on the seventh day or on
Saturday it's going back to all that we
don't promote this that much anymore
because we want to convert people but we
think the Pope is the Antichrist I see
okay so that's a but now that like we
don't honor yeah you know what the new
pope is not a bad guy he supports the
gays yeah you know he's all about these
rebrand all he's rebranding that's right
that's exactly these rebranding
Catholicism and you guys are rebranding
seven day Adventists by not promoting
the Pope as the Antichrist yeah you have
to rebrand I think that's whatever
one year every ten years if you're a
club an artist or a religion you just
have to be yourself reinvent you have to
be Madonna yeah except she doesn't
rebrand in a long time okay so tell us
more now I'm really curious George so
what you're saying is what that you you
don't disagree with her what I'm saying
though after you explained it but like
by my extended family very very
religious and very heartfelt like
they're the nicest people you like that
yes but they do take a literal
interpretation of the Bible and it's
okay I'm not saying that they're listen
I'm not saying that they're bad people
or they're not good people I'm just
saying that for me I don't hang out like
I'm not really close with people like
that yeah
because I just find it to be extreme
they're not in your hangout buds yeah
because of that way of thinking what are
your parents how do your parents feel
about your lifestyle now are they aware
of your of your lifestyle at all you
know you you seem like to me you've
always been pretty open as a person you
never I'm open there yeah not as
religious as everybody else they don't
go to church as much you know it's yeah
so they've rebranded themselves as well
important listen here guys yeah but
George do you believe in your religion
do you believe in none of those things
that still or no no say whatever you I'm
not you're still good to be in my inner
circle I just wanna no no I I don't I
just I still have like a connection I
say we still just because it's like why
we like Adventist I have an emotional
connection to it okay you know so I will
stay even though I say we it doesn't
mean I believe in it but it is how I was
raised it's a very tight community yeah
you go anywhere in the world you find an
Adventist Church just like Wow
there aren't that many of us that's you
know what I met a person from seven day
Adventist that I didn't like because one
of my nannies growing up she was 70 itit
isn't I loved her immensely my niece's
let me say this too is is that I have a
strong
association with 12-step groups like I
said and when I was in Thailand I went
to a meetings there and it was only me
and that a couple of other dudes it's
literally in a church and I went there a
lot maybe 20 times while I was in
Thailand and there is a there is a
feeling of camaraderie and when you when
you're around people that believe in the
things that you believe so I I get that
right and you were raised with that
foundation so I'm not pointing fingers
at anybody I'm just saying that there
are just certain extreme things that
people think that like especially their
opinions about a group of people that I
just don't agree with I believe that
we're all human beings we're all mammals
we're all the same you know living
beings why would you judge another right
thank you also have to this is where it
gets complicated for me because I feel
like that fundamentally we should all
understand that we were all very dour
thoughts are all varied but there are
people and many people that exist that
don't have the intellectual capacity to
even listen to the other side and that's
where it becomes a problem if you don't
have the intellectual capacity to sit
next to somebody who has opposite
thoughts from you an opposite religion
how are you able to you know how are you
able to to even understand what the [ __ ]
we're talking okay give me an example
let's say for instance you're just
you're a person born into let's say like
a but not the Westboro but let's say
you're a Christian born in a small town
and you don't exactly you're like a
Steven Avery type you're not well-read
you how you don't have a lot of
experiences outside of your small town
you don't have you know access to new
ideas to to certain things like that how
are you able to break away from your own
thoughts like how are you even if I'm
just saying though if I would hope and
maybe I'm wrong
but if I was raised in that atmosphere
and my parents were saying that like gay
people abominations I would hope that in
my own head I'd say I don't I don't buy
that I think that's a little weird that
a group of people like you would say yes
and thank God you have the aptitude you
have the genetic disposition
predisposition I don't know more but
again I don't know because the thing is
is that my parents were agnostic I never
went to you know Church really a couple
of times you'd go but you know my
parents really didn't believe in
anything so my brother and I and I
believe in God I believe in God because
of a and whatever I'm a higher power
whatever but my brother and I are open
to the idea of a spiritual entity you
know but we do it because we need to
because of our own sobriety you need to
do that in order to get real sobriety is
what they say but my point though is is
that if hey we're like you know gays
aren't permitted
I wouldn't join it but they're not like
that there are any ones inclusive it's
inclusive and there are churches like
that now there are Christian churches
that are totally inclusive
I know there are they were talking about
you know how the the Muslim
organizations in the LGBT community in
Florida often work together you know
there are gay Muslims there are gay
every religion can I ask you a question
George sure do you believe that
Christians are at fault of this Orlando
shooting just psychologically right if
you if you constantly kept hell you know
the public or your followers that gays
are an abomination
isn't that a negative stigma doesn't
matter they say that - yeah right
Muslims say that - about gays it's
exactly the same it's the exact same
thing yeah right so do you think that
religion is at fault
in a sense I think people people with
problems will seek out religion because
they're looking for answers so you can't
blame the religion for what crazy people
do in the name of religion but then with
that said what do you say about Bible
literalists and don't you think that
little Bible literally already said that
right this guy was probably a literalist
in that sense where he picked out a
portion of the Quran that says gays
ought to be dead he was radicalized in
that sense and you know he plucked it
out and provided the real problem with
religion is that you don't have an
outside moral factor so you believe that
anything God says is right because God
says it not because it is morally right
on its own right if you look at like the
Bible like Abraham was supposed to kill
his own son because I said so so like
how can you believe in something that
says that that you're gonna kill your
own son just because God says so yeah
how do you know what God's saying the
Word of God is final you're right it's
it that's the belief that the Word of
God is final no matter how it may appear
whether it seems unaware it seems
completely morally wrong its final and
that's it and that's how these people
believe in and and it is yeah yeah I'm
very conflicted every day I I don't look
at not to I don't even know how I feel
really but let's uh
gillberg it back
[Music]